[Music]
when it comes to dividing count on joe
biden yeah when it's harry's not
sniffing it's people he's splitting
true sleepy joe has americans feeling
apart which is what happens when all you
do is
bart come on all right a new poll from
monmouth university shows 49 of all
americans feel we're more divided since
biden took office 12 says we're more
united and 38 says nothing's really
changed the remaining one percent too
stupid to understand the question
anyway
meanwhile biden's stale mate kamala
harris is having a rough job lately mike
rowe has had an easier time on clogging
a latrine at a chili eating contest
we told you earlier she's not getting
along with joe and others in the white
house and the views sunny hostin knows
why
we're especially talking about kamala
harris's approval rating being 10 points
lower than his approval rating and i
think that
really speaks to where our country is
you know let's come down on on the woman
yeah let's come down on the woman no
sonny that's why you voted for her
because she's a woman so the same reason
you voted for her is the same reason you
claim some people don't like her seems
like you're both from the same sexist
club and how does that help kamala it
doesn't kamala's in more trouble than
cat's liver
we go to cat's liver for comment
oh please stop i can't take it anymore i
don't have much time left please stop
pat i love that my liver is a man yeah
my liver is a man well you drink he has
to be after all that tequila you've been
drinking you've been feeding him
is it all because she's a woman
no
okay i don't think so i mean and look
i'm sure she's had some sexist criticism
because i every woman has at some point
that doesn't automatically mean that all
criticism of you is sexist yeah you know
i've had other criticism for other
things that aren't like just because i
suck in different ways that have nothing
to do
with the fact that i'm a woman i love
the fact kellyanne that the on the the
view here are the names of people on the
view you've got sunny oh that's great
joy
doesn't that sound awesome like hey
sunny joy movie it's so much fun all
these it's like it's like a it's like a
children's birthday party
and then they're all miserable sonny's
miserable joy's miserable whoopi's just
sitting there like she's sitting in
something i don't know
no one's pointed this out i had a that's
very funny by the way i had a couple of
great experiences on the view during the
2016 campaign it's after he won and
wasn't supposed to that thing yes it
took a dark turn
however
on this one
kamala harris has earned every every bit
right every decimal point in that 28
approval rating it's not racism and
sexism it's eyesight and hearing yeah
people are listening to her watching her
in action and in action
and wondering what does she actually do
there so they have a couple of answers
she does voting rights but only here and
there and it's actually stacey abrams
who's been able to register lost the
governorship of georgia became more
powerful it's even been able to register
100 000 people there they put her in
charge of understanding the root causes
of
border insecurity of immigration she
went down to the northern triangle for a
hot second yeah came back
and doesn't seem to think we have a
crisis at our border where people are
pouring over with the secretary of
homeland security he was lying to
congress today about it so they watch
her in action and all these stories i
just want to tell you they're on cnn
they're on abc news they're on politico
this is not
right wing media right-wing media's
polls those polling numbers you're
quoting are coming from nbc abc
monmouth poll people are very much
against her i think joe biden picked in
his vice president one of three people
in the entire country who cannot upstage
him and by the way the people
complaining that it's misogyny and
sexism that she's 10 points below joe
biden as if 38 his 38 is so great
they both earned it let me just say this
yeah i think her best bet would be to
quit yeah and primary him next time and
say they never let me do anything they
never gave me any responsibility let me
tell you what's really going on there
they have the all-female
press and com shop predictably but they
have a white house chief of staff who
tweets and retweets all day he doesn't
have enough confidence in the girls who
work at the white house there you go
what do you think you always have you
have a theory on this don't you well
well for one uh as the story goes on
you can't criticize anyone who's the
first right that's true she's not only
she's the first sister she's the first
woman vp and their answer was nobody
ever brought up what pence was doing and
not doing because you couldn't leave
president trump alone pence literally
could have been running around the house
setting curtains on fire and no one
would say anything
they'd be too busy going
somehow trump's responsible for that
smoke even if pence like it's me i'm
doing it
no one would say anything
she and then they say they give her jobs
that are pointless yeah
the border is pointless yeah exactly the
only thing that they do well together is
walk towards something they they have
great
interest
in exits but when they're apart
he falls yeah and she starts doing that
giggling
so what they need to do is walk out
together right and just keep going keep
going
last word to you my friend what do you
think what's going on
oh i think yeah i mean politically
obviously there's a divide i
listening to all this go around and
around it's it's the rhetorical divide
that's so interesting you mentioned
it's like nothing means what it used to
mean right right and so when you when
you ask a people
to
ignore their eyes
over and over and over and over right
the border's okay but don't look at the
8 000 people coming in it's not you know
afghanistan's cool yes people are
dropping from the plane but you know
it's just there's some weird exponential
thing that happens when you're asked to
look at that over and over and over and
over again i don't know what to say
about the can you actually quit could
she do that no you know there's a secret
strategy here that they might try to get
her out appoint somebody who will then
replace biden when biden stops being
president in a year but how do you get
her out i mean can you quit as a vice
president what you do is you say gee she
ran for president on her own and got
exactly zero delegates i mean the
democrats all rejected her and we got
stuck with her but vice president as
victim is a terrible terrible love she
can't quit she ain't started yet
we gotta go we gotta talk about another
democrat hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else